when you see Jimmy do some of the
high-level things that he does but he
also seems to make some decisions that
are very very questionable only two
interceptions potentially game-changing
situations I mean I think I mean that's
part of football hype you get used to
that stuff
what's more frustrating to me is when
the guy can't make any plays and a guy
can't throw it at all and you just sit
there and you're beating your head
against the wall for three and a half
hours so it's nice when they do make a
lot of plays and do some good stuff but
some bad place do come with that Cal
Shanahan 49ers coach talking about Jimmy
Garoppolo and some of the interceptions
he's thrown this year he's had some good
moments he's had some bad moments in
Chris that leads into the first topic
for today's what's more likely what is
more likely Jimmy Garoppolo throws a bad
interception that cost the 49ers the
game or Jimmy G throws a game-winning
touchdown pass to deliver their tenth
win Sunday night NBC verses the Packers
I'm gonna go with number two on that one
I mean first off hey let's not forget
even though it hasn't been pretty and
perfect you know he did Drive them down
to tie the game against the Seattle
Seahawks to send in an overtime he did
drive them down last week even though
hey he might have put them in these
holes I get it he did drive him down and
throw the game-winning touchdown pass
late in the fourth quarter against the
Cardinals and I just picked door number
2 for throwing a game-winning TV TD pass
- it's just the Packers defense is it's
not good it's 28th and football its 28th
and football they can't stop the run you
and me might be able to run for a
hundred yards against the Packers which
is just gonna lead to great looks in the
pass game for Jimmy Garoppolo and that's
where I mean I think the Packers are not
in a good spot for this matchup in
general this will have to be an Aaron
Rodgers it has to pull three rabbits out
of his butt to win this game I think and
I think the 49ers understand the
importance of getting this win because
they go on the road for a couple of
tough ones after that at Baltimore net
New Orleans you lose this one
not quite the send-off that you want our
games that may be even more difficult
now the Packers have had two weeks to
get ready so yeah we'll see what Matt
Lafleur can do yep that's right and Mike
Pettine worked with Kyle Shanahan with
the Cleveland Browns of course Lafleur
came from Kyle Shanahan so there is a
lot of you know familiarity here but
pick one what are you gonna pick one or
two there I'm gonna pick one
I just we've seen the propensity from
Jimmy Garoppolo to make those bad throws
and he got lucky on that Monday night
against the Seahawks when guys were
dropping interceptions I just think with
the game on the line if we get to that
point game on the line and he's got to
make a throw
I trust Aaron Rodgers a lot more than I
trust him so I think he's gonna throw
that that if it comes down to it yeah
and we are very narrowing our choices
with what's more likely yes we are I say
interception to lose the game versus
touchdown to win the game okay that's
good especially because he's got a lot
of guys banged up who's gonna catch that
pass that is very fair kiddo may not
play right peebo Samuel may not play
Emmanuel Sanders may not play they have
to dust off marquise Goodwin no I know D
Ford's not a hundred percent they got
some issues here to where yeah there's a
little you know you know cracking the
armor for Green Bay to come in and steal
one if they have a right game plan and
Rodgers can get on fire and do those
type of things
next topic what's more likely the Eagles
defense has turned a corner or they were
propped up by a struggling New England
offense I'm going with one there I think
the Eagles defense has turned the corner
I think we saw them get healthy the last
few weeks especially in the secondary
and when they have a healthy Ronald
Darby
avanti Maddox and Jalen Mills excuse
Nick forgot for a second there those
three Fletcher Cox looks like he's a
hundred percent and back to his
disruptive self I think this is a
defense that's really quality they do
some creative things on the back end and
I think you'll see them play some
dominant football from here on out I
think the big thing really ever the
Eagles is is the offense gonna show up
can they make enough plays and do things
like that to help them win games against
the team like the Seattle Seahawks this
weekend
yeah and the offense has been the the
weaker side of the ball this year weaker
than expected and injuries have affected
the offense this year yes much in the
way that injuries affected the defense
last year for the Eagles and Doug
Peterson the coach I think was talking
about this yesterday you know they have
this this history they can draw on of
digging their way out of messes last
year they were four and six not five and
five but four and six and they found a
way to the playoffs winning five of the
last six this year they're a game ahead
of where they were there in distance
where they can pick off the Cowboys they
need this one though yes they can't
afford to lose this one to the Seahawks
if they want to try to stay close to the
Cowboys now look the Cowboys likely
gonna lose in New England so they would
still be a game back even if they lose
but this is an opportunity to force a
tie which is gonna point toward that
week 16 rematch between the Cowboys and
the Eagles but I think the defense has
turned a corner
look New England is still New England
Tom Brady is still Tom Brady I
understand the offense isn't what it's
been in past years but I think it builds
some confidence for the defense even
though they lost the game and that
should help them against Russell Wilson
yep all right next topic what's more
likely
deshaun Watson jumps back into the MVP
conversation or he fades out of it down
the stretch yeah this is this is a tough
one because he is an MVP talent I just
don't know how good their team is right
now and and I think right now when I sit
here and look at it you know I think
Lamar Jackson and Russell Wilson have
separated themselves from the rest of
football in this conversation and then
in that next group you have Kirk Cousins
and dak Prescott right maybe Christian
McCaffrey is just hanging on the edge
but that seems to be kind of dying out
too so I think I'm gonna go with he fade
he he fades out down the stretch just
because III don't know if they're a good
enough football team in general to to
stay relevant in that MVP conversation
and I think stats and big games will be
hard to come by as well yeah I think it
begins tonight yeah when they they
they're gonna have their hands full
against the Colts and and look deshaun
Watson is a great quarterback yeah but
you have to have help around you and I
just don't think as you've said he's got
the kind of help around him that other
great
quarterbacks have whether it's Patrick
mahomes whether it's Lamar Jackson any
of the great young quarterbacks out
there he's more like and he's more like
in a Cuyler Murray type of a situation
but Watson is good enough to get those
extra wins that Murray in time will be
able to get on his own
Watson is good for what three four wins
by himself every year but that's not
enough to turn a team that otherwise has
the cupboard bear into a championship
contender and what it does is if you're
not gonna make it to the playoffs or
you're gonna make it as a wild card it's
going to drag down an MVP candidacy and
it's gonna make it hard for him to be in
the conversation I see it exactly right
that's kind of where I'm with you I
think he'll do plenty of great things
down the stretch but they're gonna lose
some games we're gonna go uh how did
they lose that or why did they lose that
and then you know you hit it they're
just not they need will forward to be
100% healthy they need those guys to
help him out and of course we said it
earlier their defense is just not very
good this year and that's a big problem
for them the big game on Sunday
afternoon for 25 p.m. Eastern kickoff
from Foxborough the Cowboys at the
Patriots way more likely Bill Belichick
tries to take away dak Prescott or
Belichick game plans to stop Ezekiel
Elliott I think it's all about dak
Prescott right now I do
Dallas offense is a pass offense this is
dak Prescott steam yeah you know you've
heard me say and I will continue to say
it Ezequiel it's been underwhelming this
year I'd be concerned I really would be
it's just not as explosive as it once
was he doesn't do special things they
kind of they kind of put you know Tony
Pollard in the game a little bit more
last week too and got him touches and he
brings some juice to the offense when he
gets the ball in his hands so yeah I'm
gonna go with takes away dak Prescott
because right now that's what Dallas is
they're about big chunks in the passing
game it's Cooper downfield it's gallop
downfield it's Randall Cobb down the
middle and then you know a little tight
end and bootleg play-action stuff all of
that too to go with it so I think Bill
Belichick will be more concerned with
that than Ezekiel Elliott in the run
game kind of reminds me of the Super
Bowl twenty five game plan when
Belichick was a defensive coordinator to
the Giants remember he had to sell to
that Giants defense if Thurman Thomas
has over 100 rushing yards will win the
game right
they thought he was nuts when he trotted
that out there now that was more about
taking the KGUN offense out of play and
keeping it from hitting hitting on all
cylinders that's kind of what the
Cowboys offense is becoming it's
becoming a passing offense you've got a
quarterback he's on pace for 50-100
passing yard he's on fire you're right
you're exactly right hey I'll say this
much too III will not be shocked if
Dallas went up to New England and won
this game this this week you know
they're a little desperate they pose
some problems for the New England
Patriots they do you know a little bit
like Baltimore this way Mike where you
know of course we know Dallas has these
weapons on the outside and Prescott's on
fire throwing the ball and they're a
creative offense with Kellen Moore and
the things he's doing but the other
thing is they don't have a lot of big
people in New England as far as
defensive tackles it's Lawrence guy and
Danny Sheldon and and then a bunch of
linebackers behind it they mix and match
and do all these different things behind
it where you know the Dallas can pose
some problems with their offensive line
if it can have a good day and a good
game plan to where bill might be in a
bind of going oh man I'm worried about
this pass game but we are getting
overpowered a little bit up front you
know some of my linebackers and people
like that can't hold up against these
big hulking offensive linemen the
Cowboys have so that's where I find it
interesting and of course we know know
England's offense is not great right now
and Dallas's defense is still talented
and has a front forward that I think
could be a pain in the butt for the New
England Patriots so I'm going to pick
the Patriots to win but it's one of
those where I think it will go down too
late in the fourth quarter and be very
close it would be a stunner if the
Cowboys pulled it off in part because
the perception / reality for the Cowboys
this year is when they get into those
big games they don't win it when the
games are supposed to win except when
they play the Jets but they otherwise
can't deliver in the games that that are
close tough matchups and they need to
bust through that if they want to do as
good as they're supposed to be this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports